you can only have a competitor in a
finite game right in in a game of
baseball or football
um
you want to beat your competitor
and then the game ends but the
competitors live on to fight another day
right that's what happens
uh in uh
but in business there are there is no
such thing as winning or losing
um at a macro level when we talk about
winning in a game that cannot be won
what ends up happening is we focus uh
too much on beating the enemies we look
to exploit their weaknesses or because
we pick our own metrics and our time
frames to exaggerate those things in the
short term but we're not actually
building a stronger company a healthier
way to view
another player in an infinite game is
instead of thinking of them as a
competitor to be beaten you think of
them as rivals
some of those rivals are worthy of
comparison
meaning they do one or many things
better than you um
and uh their strengths reveal to you
your weaknesses
and so we should be grateful for the
other players in the game and instead of
trying to beat them
we can learn from them so the best
example i can offer is a personal is a
at least at least it's a funny example
it's a personal story i had the
opportunity to speak at a an education
summit for microsoft i also had an
opportunity to speak in an education
summit for apple
at the microsoft summit the vast
majority of the executives spent the
vast majority of their presentations
talking about how they were going to
beat apple
at the apple summit 100 of the
executives spent 100 of their
presentations talking about talked about
how they were going to help teachers
teach and help students learn one was
obsessed with their mission the other
one was obsessed with beating their
competition right
at the end of my talk at microsoft they
gave me a gift they gave me the new zune
when it was a thing that was microsoft's
response to the ipod and if you listen
to any of the press that microsoft put
out at the time or anything that steve
ballmer said
they were going to beat apple right that
was their obsession
so at the end of my apple talk i was
sharing a taxi with one of the senior
executives and i couldn't help myself i
had to stir the pot
and i turned him and i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zune
it is so much better than my ipod touch
and he looked at me and he said
i have no doubt and the conversation was
over
what he understood is sometimes you have
the better product and sometimes they
have the better product sometimes you're
ahead and sometimes you're behind
there's no winning or losing
and because microsoft was obsessed with
beating apple all of their focus and
attention went on to making a better
ipod
right where apple was more obsessed
without doing themselves they couldn't
care less what microsoft was doing and
about a year later apple introduced the
iphone which rendered both the zoom and
the ipod completely obsolete
and that's the point the innovation that
came out of the organization didn't come
because they were trying to best
their competitor came from trying to
best themselves
and so
in the infinite game of business we need
to stop trying to beat our competitors
and start identifying um which of our
which of the other people who do what we
do
do some things or many things better
than us maybe better leadership better
training better marketing whatever it is
and say okay
let's up our game because business is a
game where two people two players can
offer a similar product at similar price
and both be wildly successful at the
same time
so it's a fool's errand to try and win
it doesn't doesn't make sense
at the midst of
the pandemic kicking off we
ventilators were in very high demand
open sourced our ventilator patent
another example is the ventilator
training alliance that you that you
offered some free advice to me on right
where it was
we were not only trying to train on our
products but we trained our we helped
our competitors train on this platform
so some people would say
that's not good business to help your
competitors what's flawed in their
thinking um they don't understand
business when you say what's good
business the best players in business
play for the good of the game
right that's what the infinite game is
it's for the good of the game and it and
it and at the end of the day the good of
the game means it's good for all
business
i mean at the end of the day um it's the
right thing to do from from a moral and
ethical standpoint like would was it
illegal for you to hoard your patents no
of course not would people have faulted
you for it maybe maybe not you know um
but did it build trust with people yes
will it make you uh the go-to uh company
of choice even if you're slightly more
expensive later down the road highly
likely will people come to you advice
and turn down somebody else who was more
finite and selfishly driven did you
demonstrate that you actually care about
other people other than yourselves yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes and in the short
term yes it costs you something of
course it did right in the long term
it'll pay dividends
way more than whatever whatever was
spent in the short term so i think
anybody who thinks it's a fool's errand
to do that who thinks that that's not
business all they're doing is revealing
themselves as finite players and all
they're doing is revealing themselves a
short-term mindset